[Music]
hi everyone yeah thanks for attending my
talk so today we'll be talking about
Marquez it's an open source solution for
the aggregation collection and
visualization of metadata around our
data ecosystem we're also going to sort
of the how you can use Marquez to
explore and visualize your data sets and
also things like enabling data
abstraction data lineage and event based
triggers but you know first let me
introduce myself I'm Willie a data
engineer at we work I work on the open
source project Marquez so we kind of
focus on making datasets meaningful and
discoverable using datasets and of
course I'm at Twitter ws and Luke so
before we go into my talk I do want to
introduce we work a little bit so one
thing that we do provide is space so
that's really providing an environment
for teams of any sizes to collaborate
that means booking rooms sort of
providing kitchens so that way people
can go and sort of have lunch and and
and and fresh coffee we also provide a
community so that's we have an internal
app that allows people to connect with
one another whether it's local within
there we work or globally and so you
could imagine hey I have some UX sort of
mock-ups that I'm looking for feedback
on and maybe getting feedback from a
JavaScript developer or someone in
design and so that's the kind of app for
your offers we do you have and then the
last last one is services so things like
so we take care of IT we do provide
things around payroll and and so forth
right now we work we have over 250,000
members globally 280s almost 300
physical locations were in 72 cities and
23 countries so for my talk today we're
gonna we're gonna look into those sort
of a sequester and wide metadata and
really what that means is why
contextualize your data we're going to
look into a room booking pipeline so we
work you know one of the big things is
people wanted book rooms mainly is if
it's for interviews or if they sort of
want to do one-on-ones room bookings is
a pretty important part
of joining joining we work we're gonna
look into sort of the naive approach of
how you you define that pipeline not
using Marquez and then I'm going to go
into sort of the quick intro into
Marquez and then revisit that same
pipeline sort of addressing some of the
problems that do come up but solving
them with Marquez and then we'll go into
sort of feature work for the for the
project and you know maybe get someone
you someone from the audience to you
come and contribute to the project so
why why metadata well you want to manage
and utilize metadata mainly for data
quality so you know a lot of the time
you kind of go into an organization
maybe it's your first day and you kind
of ask okay you guys are data so you
guys are data-driven that's great let me
know all about your meta your data and
usually you just get well we have
redshift we have a data warehouse and
that's where all of our data is so
really that equates to a data blob and
there's actually no context and the
tables do help but is the data quality
where it should be our fields missing
what kind of are we doing validation at
the row level call them level things
like that so you do want to build trust
in there in your data so that way when
it'll say if I'm a data scientist and
I'm getting data from a data engineer or
different team you want to make sure
that you know what you validated your
data you sort of made sure that the it's
the data set is well documented and
there's an owner associated with that
the other one becomes data lineage so
that's really comes out what that really
means is what's the origin of your data
set and what direct what data sets were
derived based off that data set so as
data goes it makes its way in through
your Data Platform
there'll be things like transformations
filtering and and so forth you want to
know what stages of your data went
through throughout throughout its its
time so you could think about data
lifecycle management in that case the
other one becomes democratization of
data sets that's pretty critical so you
should be able to look sort of get it
really you should be able to get a view
of your data landscape so if I so again
if it's my first day
and I want to know what data sets or
what data sets are accessible to me if I
have to see you write a report or do
some analysis it would be great to know
that I have a central portal or some UI
that I can start searching for data sets
and that's really building a
self-service data culture so now really
asking teams but really being more like
ok let me answer the questions myself
because I have the tools to do it and
that's all leading to creating a healthy
data ecosystem so a few things sort of
that we already talked about but
self-service really about discovery and
exploration and providing that global
context so the freedom to experiment so
you could think here and if I'm going to
start looking at different data sets now
that I have the ability to discover and
explore the difference data sets in my
org I didn't want to then write jobs
that use those data sets to you know
maybe maybe generate different reports
that I find interesting then be able to
deploy jobs into my platform with and
have the flexibility where I can say
here are the data sets for my job and at
that point go ahead and produce the the
output data sets as well so it's all
about being self-sufficient I think
that's that's kind of what at that point
trying to make and a force of
accountability and these are two things
one is that if your job is running and
is producing producing data is it
producing 250 gigs a week a day you want
to associate the amount of data that a
team produces to sort of say hey you
know you guys are sort of really high
offenders maybe there's a reason for it
but you do want to associate cost to
teams based off the data that they
produced so in the in the past I've sort
of ran jobs and it's mostly about
dealing with ok so there's a QA on so we
have customer customer support and so
one wants to know hey this person has
booked you know 50 rooms in the past
month and I wanted to sort of get a
report on that so sometimes you can't
really associate that with a cost this
sort of as a data engineer ok I'll do it
I'll write the job and sort of run it
but how do you use how do you sort of
validate that what data engineering is
doing is providing value
so the one way you could do that is
associated costs like this is obviously
a week there's obviously reason why we
ran that job and of course Trust is the
other thing so if I'm accountable for my
datasets and I make sure that they are
valid and that I put in the time to sort
of provide descriptions and so forth
maybe at the field level or column level
if I'm if it's going to be a table that
you do build that trust across teams
because a lot of time what you do see is
sort of teams that are very siloed and
data scientists they're very savvy so if
they don't trust your data they'll have
scripts that pulling in to pull in from
direct data data sources into their own
worldview and then you kind of get that
sort of sort of disjunction between
between teams so okay so back to the
room booking and sort of pipeline that
we're going to be working on let's
actually book a room and see what that
looks like so the first thing we're
gonna do is choose a location and floor
in this case and as you know we have a
new new office actually opened up in SF
so I'm going to choose a sales for Tower
and we have about two members that I'm
looking to book a room for so we're
going to need about 1 or 4 seats and
it's some time today actually
so that's awkward so the other one is
we're going to choose an open time time
slot here we're actually some peak hours
so I found one towards the end of the
day because everyone enjoys late
meetings but in this case is from 4:00
to 5:00 that's a bummer
the other one then we're gonna actually
confirm come from that booking so it's
generally the flow and what we're going
to we're actually tasked with now is
your shirt oozing which location has the
most bookings so seems pretty obvious
that it kind of equates to this we have
a set of room bookings and we just want
to know the top location okay so we're
gonna approach it in a naive way but to
be honest with you I think a lot of
people approach it this way so it's
actually quite quite all right the
requirements that we have is we're just
going to read a room bookings from some
data source we don't know yet we're
gonna sum those room bookings and return
the top location so that's come your
business logic so we're going to write
that top location once we do calculate
it
into some output data source and of
course we're going to run it once an
hour so let's say we you know reach out
to some teens we kind of eventually
figured out that you know what our input
data for room bookings is in s3 and it's
going to be in a CSV file that's great
because that's easy to parse and also
get wrong so here we're gonna have a
location in this case just some ID and
some time stamp in which the booking
actually happened and also the room so
in this case it's just going to be a
room number and what our business logic
is going to do is just going to say
great let me process that CSV file for
that particular hour and we're just
going to read insert a record into our
Postgres database that says here's the
recursive table location for that
particular time that we ran the job and
we're also going to take into account
the bookings so the reason for that is
that we're going to plot these data
points so it's kind of would be nice to
know how many room bookings happen at
during during that hour so this is
actually not too bad this is what we
have it's running and I feel pretty good
about it you know there's a lot of steps
that went into it that we didn't really
go deep into but in general we do have a
job with a that represents our workflow
that reasons from s3 and rights to
Postgres and we have a scheduler so run
on an interval of every hour but we do
have some interesting dependencies one
is the upstream dependency there's some
job that owns bison that's owned by some
team that's archiving the data the room
bookings into s3 and the other one
becomes well we do have a tree a
downstream dependency well the dashboard
has an upstream dependency on our
workflow so we do have to make sure that
we're providing those data points in a
timely timely manner so those are
actually some problems so here we're
gonna actually keep track of problems
that we run into you while we're defined
this our pipeline one of them is going
to be what's our jobs input dataset so a
lot of time you know you do either you
slack or miss someone directly or send
out an uncomfortable email by the way I
need room booking data room bookings are
where can I find them is it in database
are they serve distributed in s3 and
also a database those questions actually
do come up and stuff things that do need
to be answered the other one becomes
does the data set have an owner a lot of
time it doesn't I've experienced in the
past where I asked for a data set and
someone says yeah it's being pulled into
our data warehouse from from a cron that
no one really knows why it's being
pulled in but it actually makes its way
into our the calculations for Android
and and report and I'm like oh okay
that's interesting so we definitely want
to know who the owner is that's pretty
critical and also how often is the data
set updated just in general because we
want to know how often we need to run
our job so in our case we our
requirement was updating updating it
every hour but is that really what's
happening in that data set itself so we
were told it was every hour but do we
really trust that team that's that's
what we want to answer so great we were
running a production and I can't
remember the last time I wrote a bug so
I'm a little confused on what's going on
here so we have a job that's failing
that's great and I think logs are really
efficient and sort of a cheap way to
figure out what's going on when your job
is failing so I checked the logs and I'm
like oh okay
we're seeing serialization exception or
D serialization exceptions everywhere in
the logs so I'm thinking this might be
our input data set which actually is
they actually changed the type of the
field for rooms so even eventually they
said you know what we need to also count
for rooms with letters so these ended up
just changing the type of room bookings
from an integer to a string to account
for the character that comes after would
have been great if I was told about that
so let's actually add that to our
problem we need to coordinate changes
cuz I don't want to be woken up through
two o'clock in the morning about some
some change specific to an upstream
dependency unless you guys do I'm not
sure but we want to weed so we want to
we want to fix that I was able to
realize what's going on it was a quick
patch so
but before we get to that we do want to
actually note that there's gaps in our
output dataset because remember we do
have a dashboard that relies on the
output of our job every hour now this
one's important because I think our CEO
is looking at it so we got it we got to
fix this so the the okay I'm sorry it
looked weird on my screen so we do have
to account for gaps in our data at one
point our job did stop in this case from
our 6 & 7 our job star stopped actually
producing producing wrote
so let's actually add that to our
growing list of problems we need to
figure out backfills
so to recap what we have so far we have
a job that I feel pretty good about it
doesn't handle things all that well and
we did have to explore and understand
where our input was coming from the
downstream dependencies in our case was
a dashboard so we have to always think
that I think about that particular
dashboard in the back of our mind and we
have now a job that runs on a schedule
and we also have these lists of problems
so that's a lot but writing a job
shouldn't be this hard
and if you're thinking that I was
actually thinking the same thing before
I joined Wiegert and now actually a lot
of the things that we're addressing at
we work really has this sort of question
this question always always comes up and
what we ended up coming up with was
marques so it's an open source project
that should and will actually help
resolve a lot of the problems that we
ran into in our example pipeline so
first and foremost its metadata service
so as you can imagine you have jobs that
are running and they're reporting
metadata about its runtime sort of what
its inputs and output data sets are and
all the things this we actually capture
all this metadata through REST API s so
at the core of marques it's just the
centralized metadata management so a
great catalog of metadata about your
jobs and datasets it's also modular so
there's things like data discovery data
health and data triggers which we will
go into individually and kind of expand
on
on those ideas but they are all built
around the core model of marques and the
metadata that is collecting so the first
module is search and that's just a
unified search so before I talked about
you know what makes a really solid data
echo a data ecosystem is search search
ability of your data sets and that's
something that's built into marques so
as jobs are reporting its inputs and
output data sets you then will be able
to start indexing sort of doing sinks
from the court the core database into a
search engine and start indexing and
ranking based off a few things so
possibly it could be does your data set
have a description if so we'll probably
want to bump that up and also in this
case we're looking for documentation so
like owner schema and data sources
that's very important to us and thumb
something we should be we should be
collecting so generally what that kind
of looks like I'm going to search for
room bookings and I'll go ahead and get
some tags associated with my searches so
for room bookings an SF that data
sources in s3 so you could think of tags
are just a way to add even more context
or more metadata on the metadata that
you're collecting so another example
with maybe be PII but in this case
that's not really a concern and of
course you get a list of all the data
sets that match that search term the
other one becomes health so this in
general is like well you know I want to
know generally are the values are the
values that are present in that data set
those data points are they correct
are they are they actually accurate are
there gaps in the data itself and
doesn't have a schema I want to know
that if I'm reading a data set that I
know that types the field of the fields
and also the description and at the same
time I also want to know where it's
located and if you look at the sort of
the for the second to the last point
there about size you kind of want to
know over time how your data set
actually grows if you start seeing drops
there could be sort of an upstream issue
with the job that's producing that data
set and you want to be what you kind of
want to have those type of checks to
make sure that something didn't actually
go wrong so you want to see growth over
time and also the number of
kurz would also be be great to know as
well and sort of the last piece with
lineage once you have sort of general
view and you kind of know what teams
owned what datasets you'll be able to
start running Linnaeus queries so well
sexy step into that so if you have a
data graph and in this case we have
nodes that represent jobs and the edges
themselves are just sort of containers
of data and they represent data sets so
Elena's query kind of looks like this
where I have a data set and I want to
know how it got to this point what jobs
did it go through over time that
resulted in the the data set that I
currently have now so I want to know the
origin and the process the the
transformations that happened so the
last module is triggers so this is all
about timely processing of data so right
now what you kind of have is sort of a
framework that usually wakes wakes a
process up and says is this job done or
is my data that I'm expecting where at
where it should be so we want to remove
that sort of hole thatthat sort of
resource intensive process out of the
equation so no pulling I'm pretty
excited about that the the other one
becomes a reduction of manually handling
back fills so I'm not sure about you but
a lot of the time I get very much rushed
into producing a pipeline and what would
happen is I usually rarely ever think
about back fills because that's usually
requires a separate approach it's not
really a one-to-one mapping is like okay
I need to rerun a pipeline and that's it
usually there's a little bit more
involved
so we want to reduce that and also the
reduce the production of bad data so
what I mean by that is that if your job
does come up and there is data in that
s3 bucket for example it might not be
all the data that you expect so you
could have it where the data that makes
its way into that that bucket that you
expect is about 15 minutes behind so
you're only working with a portion of
the data the only becomes low-quality
avoiding the low quality data so what I
mean by that is that if you do trigger
so let's say in this case we have the
module trigger that's listening for data
changes so as new data arrives it will
be able to say okay there's new data
that's great it's complete but is the
data quality there so if if you could
think about payments that's a pretty big
one so you don't want to get that wrong
so if there's an upstream bug that
you're aware about you don't want to
actually trigger the jobs downstream
that depend on that data set especially
if you're dealing dealing with payments
so here's an example where we have a job
that's failing upstream and here are the
affected paths so if I'm downstream from
this I'm probably getting alerts and I'm
a little concerns like what's going on
but with Marquez and this visual
component of it you'll be able to
actually do a quick search lineage
search to see where the data is what's
the path of the data and then actually
have the sort of visual component where
if the job is read and for example
there's actually an outage so if you
click on that node you'll be able to
know the owner and how to contact them
so let's say we do and we call them up
like yo what's going on and like I were
already looking into it and we're
applying a patch so I'm like oh that was
easy I'll go back to sleep so let's when
they do apply the patch will actually
have cascading triggers so they'll apply
the patch in their code and then at that
point any Street any job downstream will
actually get the trigger event to say
hey by the way there's new data that you
have to process we possibly rewrite that
data that was bad and insert this new
data into into your your database or or
something like that I think that's
really convenient there's very little
involvement there it's all sort of down
through sis through system of system
calls
so let's actually walking walking
through some of the core concepts of
Marquez so when everyone thinks about
jobs they usually think about an input
and output data set so we have a job
working with a static input data set and
writing a static output
you said but what marques actually
introduces is the notion of versions so
a version is really just a snapshot of
your data at some point in time so you
could keep adding data and it will
actually justify okay i'm sailin my next
slide actually cover that so you have
this you keep adding data and that could
be an insertion into a table every time
you do that insertion it does create a
new immutable version of that data set
so then you could do things like Delta
so what was the different
what was the diff or Delta between
version 2 and version 3 because you do
have different types of jobs one is not
incremental jobs which just say I'm
going to just going to process data from
scratch then you do have some that are
incremental where they just want to work
with the diff so it's kind of nice to
know what difference what words the
differ between version 2 and version 3
of the data set and the other one
becomes for incremental so again in that
case it's the same concept that's new
non-incremental it's just processing
entire data set and it wants to work
with the current version of the data set
we also Marquez actually introduces the
concept of job versioning in this case
so anytime your business object changes
for example you will have a get sha
associated with that we actually want to
collect to know what job is associated
with that with that change or what code
was associated with that change so that
way we can tie very input versions of a
data set to the its output version we
also do capture job runs as a job runs
we do actually begin we do salt a new
job version two new and as it's running
it's going to communicate to Marquez hey
I'm running changed my state when I'm
finished
the data set part will actually Marquez
will note ok this data set has now been
updated we want to actually trigger
trigger jobs to actually process that
that new version of the data set there
are also things around job failures so a
job will be running and they do fail
quite often so we also want reports
Taylor
a state of failure now it's possible
that a job can't report its failures so
we are looking into things like a job
timeout and after let's say maybe 30
minutes we want to flip the the state of
that job to failed and that reason why
that's important is that you do if your
data set is delayed so are the
downstream jobs dependency on that on
that data set so they all get delayed so
what are some design benefits one is
early upstream failure detection which
we we kind of look through that allows
you to say you know what my job is
failing I need to look into it really
quickly because there are downstream
jobs that depend on my job completing
and also debugging so when you have job
versions and dataset versions you'd be
able to run queries to say what if I
have urgent two of my job what were the
version of the data set that resulted in
that chopped running as a recoverability
which I went through went through a sort
of fool incremental processing so as
jobs different jobs have different
requirements and one reading from
scratch sort of the job saying I'm gonna
wipe out my data whether it's a table
I'm going to wipe it out run my
computation and repopulate it with the
resulting calculations from that new
data set version of course coordination
just as we're on cross cross team
coordination you know if something does
go wrong it's you were easy easily able
to identify the owner of that job and
the owner of the of the data set so now
we're actually going to look into the
data model of marques at a really high
level there's a lot more involved in
kind of what you see here what we can go
through but at the very high level we
have jobs that have one or more versions
and those versions have one or more data
sets and here when I say data sets I'm
talking about logical names of data sets
so it's sort of a universal global name
that people can identify a data set it's
actually not tied to the job itself we
tie those to the versions so initially
when you register a job it's sort of a
really really sort of basic metadata
that you would expect through the
description the owner
and the input and output data sets but
those the inputs and output data sets
get tied to a job version when you make
an API call which allows you to do job
run so every version a job version
creates instances of job runs and those
actually produce the data set versions
so as for job completes it does need to
write to the physical store whether it's
s3 so if you're appending to an s3
bucket you will actually do that first
and then you'll actually tell Marquez by
the way I've updated my room bookings
dataset with new data I need to I need
to actually version it which puts us
into the data source types so at a high
level we care about DB tables we do care
about file systems at versioning
versioning file systems and stream so
streaming with we work we do have a huge
initiative for IOT de IOT data around
our office space so we're looking into
streaming lineage in terms of metadata
collection it's actually done through an
API nothing too crazy here we do have a
diverse set of languages use that we
work and we need language specific SDKs
and one of them two of them actually is
going to be Python and Java so as a job
is running it's going to be reporting to
marques via an API call as we scale I
think there's going to be different ways
we do approach this but I think to get
to use sort of gain adoption it's all
going to be done through HTTP and then
maybe in the future we're looking into
processing log files and stitching
things together that way but what we
care about in terms of data collection
is when a job does come up and has to
connect to a data source that's the
that's the area that we really do care
about and that's where we want report
metadata to be sent to marques and at
the end of the job we're asked to
connect to that data source where I has
to write to that becomes a pretty
critical component as well we're not
really capturing lineage or
transformation that happened within the
job but just other that's sort of at a
high level at the job at the job level
what are the inputs and output data sets
generally what that workflow looks like
is a job is registered in this case draw
version the inputs and output data sets
the logical names the owner and
description so what I mentioned before
we do register a job run what what this
kind of looks like is you do make an API
call out to a job and you sort of
execute a run and you get back a run ID
which is unique that you could then
start updating state so you update the
job stayed at different parts where you
start and complete and then when you
finally finish with your processing
after you've ingested your data you want
to register the output and data set in
this case it's going to be the physical
location because eventually marques
needs to know where that data set is
located so it needs a pointer to that
data source so we're actually going to
revisit the room bookings pipeline and
see how marques can help out so recall
we had to analyze we had a task to
analyze room booking trends and we came
up with something pretty decent we had a
job and s3 was our input and the output
was Postgres feeding a dashboard that
kept trends of top locations and we also
had these set of problems and let's
actually address them of one by one yeah
but this case using marques so we're
going to use the UI to search for room
bookings
before we had to either send out an
email or do a really you know do it out
here out of the slack in a slack channel
which no one really likes to find out
where the room bookings datasets are and
here it was actually pretty easy we were
able to find it almost immediately with
daily since we're indexing all the
datasets that we're collecting and here
we have all datasets a few things that
so when we click on the room book sync
data set we actually know a few things
about about that data set one being the
owner so in this case the data
engineering and it's updated hourly and
also we know the location it's in
semester II bucket called room bookings
and it's going to be the raw raw values
but as a bonus we do get the schema so
we work our data platform uses the
Coughlin schema registry and this was
just a pointer to to that schema in this
case the version is it was actually the
first version so it's version 1 so in
this case we what's our jobs input
dataset we knew rooms of room bookings
we know where it's located so we could
check that off
does the dataset have an owner we
actually do know that it's data
engineering great and the other one
becomes the other question that we had
was how often is the data set updated we
know that it's hourly now we could check
that off we're actually doing pretty
good
so if we go to the next problem we also
have to coordinate changes of our input
data set so in our view we only see room
bookings as it failing and we had this
upstream dependency that was archiving
or data set but really if you look at a
global view there was actually
unexpected uses of our top locations we
thought it was just feeding a dashboard
but there was actually other engineers
that realized that that was an
interesting data set that they wanted to
use so they started writing jobs that
used our calculations that's a surprise
to me at least so in this case we also
want we're going to use marques to
figure out how we can get to that data
the change in the dataset so remember
that we had the CSV file the date the
type of the data set of the type of the
room the booking and the room number
changed from an into a string if we were
using a schema registry which now
marques kind of forces you to provide
schemas for your data sets so now we
just realize oh there was a version bump
let's actually patch the code deploy and
then trigger downstream jobs so in terms
of coordination this one is a little
interesting I mean there is sort of
still required the 2d bugs like hey I
did my job is failing but you don't have
to reach out to a team you could just
use
the the marques UI to realize you know
what I have an input data set let me
just see the last time it was updated
and it does allow sort of the
self-service notion to debug your
problem so we could coordinate
coordinate changes is still still kind
of a problem but we could check it off
because now it doesn't require me to go
to a team I can just kind of solve those
those data problems myself and also
backfill since we do utilize triggers we
can actually remove back backfills from
the from the issue as well because it's
no longer a manual process we can patch
our code and the marques will realize
that that job just finished it has an
output data set and we can actually
trigger trigger downstream jobs that
depend on that dataset so to recap we
wanted to make datasets trivial to
discover and with the marques UI and the
metadata that's collected I think we
achieve that we also wanted to use
metadata for global context for
debugging so if our jobs failing and our
datasets are not in a healthy state we
want to be able to identify what the
problem is really quickly the other one
becomes easily handling of backfills
which triggers there's a lot more you
can do than just backfills but that is
what we used it for and it actually
makes data sets as dependencies and
reverses jobs depend sort of
dependencies between jobs and we we kind
of say well dependencies are the most
datasets are the most critical part in
data pipeline because a lot of people
when they write pipelines they think
well I have to write code and it's gonna
produce some data but I don't really
care about the output well they do but a
lot of the time you don't you have a lot
of tools for visualizing what happens at
the code level but right now there's
very little in terms of what happens
when you actually produce your data set
and how healthy health have healthy it
is so I think there could be a lot more
done to visualize and provide the right
context to sort of debug those type of
problems so future work one thing is
important we work does use marques
pretty heavily and we do have a team
that supports the the maintaining and
development of features and marques is
built around our data platform is built
around marques so the core of our
platform is around a metadata around
metadata and then we're building
integrations with scheduling so we have
a team New York dealing that manages
scheduling and actual actually just
airflow so we're looking at integrating
marques with air flow and using marques
to trigger workflows in air flow and it
doesn't replace air flow it just sort of
says hey by the way we have possibly
five or ten instances of air flow
running and that could be every instance
could be mapped to a team or a
particular use case we want to we want
to be able to say you know what one
workflow from one airflow instance just
finished and how do we trigger that
other workflow that's in a separate
instance and the way you could do that
is with triggers for marques the other
becomes batching the abstraction part is
actually pretty important here so we
have a batching layer a team out in
tel-aviv which is managing our spark our
spark cluster and we're looking into
using marques as a way to say I have a
job and I have logical names for my
inputs and output data sets and there's
a thin data API client that says tell me
actually where this data source is
located as where's the physical location
of the data and then it actually
continues computation and the only one
since again we are we're really looking
in exploring the IOT space streaming
becomes a really important one so stream
leading-edge is actually really tough
problem so I do have office hours after
this so if anyone wants to talk about
that that'd be amazing
so our roadmap short term we have a
release of marques it's where we're
looking at a zero one zero release and
that's really just finalizing the the
API so we have a job API data set API
and one thing I didn't talk about was
namespaces so you want to be able to
group your jobs based off some context
so you have uniqueness within a day
within a namespace for your jobs and
datasets but you want to tie owners to
namespaces and that's that's sort of the
API is that we're looking at finalizing
and again there's an open PR around the
open API spec so if anyone wants to you
provide feedback
that'd be great and of course we're
we're looking at providing more
documentation around sort of the goal
the goal of the project and long term I
think it's very critical that the UI
becomes a portal that people can go to
from different backgrounds where this
where the marketing data Sciences data
data engineers the UI becomes the visual
component of all the metadata that
you've collected and queries that you'll
be running to event to actually start
visualizing it and create graphs around
around you around your data landscape so
here's again if you want to work on
marques we do we do have a Twitter
handle check us out and also here's our
github link if you if anyone's
interested and contributing that's
really all I had actually so thanks
[Music]
thanks for the talk first of all I had a
question about the data set versioning
is that trying to understand the purpose
of it is it kind of an implementation
detail to just say getro since yesterday
or is it a way to to like freeze a query
or an export in time and be able to
replay it at a later date it's that
latter part right it's the immutability
to say you know what was that current
state because you all have jobs so if
you look at as we're collecting metadata
around job versions that version of that
job and that run has to be mapped to the
dataset version that it produced so in
order to actually understand so a lot of
time what happens when you're debugging
a problem it's actually a week until you
actually figure out what's going on so
if you can't relate it back to that job
version that code that produced that
dataset version it doesn't really help
out with debugging so yeah thanks for
the talk in terms of integrations with
other systems you mentioned using air
flow but for other tools like the ouija
or whatnot
how easy would it be to integrate with
other systems with that mostly evolved
api calls back and forth quick pretty
much yeah so with air flow what we're
looking at doing so you know this was
kind of nice air flood does have an API
that you can actually kick off workflows
so what we're thinking about doing is
we're providing a really clean interface
that you can actually plug in
so for triggering you can say okay
here's an interface that will send a
message to whatever channel like Kafka
or sqs and if you have a process listing
downstream on those events you can just
say okay I've have a new data set
version I know what workflows to execute
so that's really what integration comes
in and we're looking for contributions
from all types of systems there's one
other with AWS glue I don't know if
people didn't do that at all since that
does data cataloguing and discovery as
well go today integrations between oh no
I haven't but let's talk after here sure
all right
last question so the way Marcus works is
it takes the place of the scheduler and
our flow works just like like the dag
pipeline thing so Marcus is actually
responsible for triggering the jobs
right it's not it's sort of a light
trigger in the end workflow still man
I'm sorry airflow still manages to work
flow and still matter internally still
schedules it still keeps dependencies
but marques is sort of saying hey you
might want to trigger this workflow
because some some dependency on a
particular workflow that airflow is
managing needs to kick off so it's sort
of a it's a partnership and certainly
not a replacement are you guys already
using in production
airflow no Marcus so right now we're
actually working so we have a initial
release out that has been collecting
metadata and we're constantly iterating
on it so the version zero-one-zero
release has a lot to do from the
learnings and that we've been we've been
so it's we have some beta teams that are
testing it out and we've learned a lot
from that
[Music]